[Musique]
dans cette promotion vous avez 23 femmes
pour 110 110 personnel en tout mais
l'école de gendarmerie a une capacité
aujourd'hui de six promotions six
compagnies donc un peu plus de 700 les
élèves viennent de toute la france et
d'outre-mer afin la france
métropolitaine et d'outre-mer
ces huit mois de formation ici à l'école
et ensuite un stage en dans leur unité
lors d'une été un stage pratique si je
puis dire avec un tutorat dans une
formation géré en plusieurs temps il ya
un temps de formation initiale
découverte du monde militaire discipline
la gendarmerie c'est une force armée
donc qui remplit des missions de police
mais reste force militaire et ensuite on
entrent progressivement dans le métier
de gendarme avec toutes les techniques
d'intervention de contrôler les jeunes
qui sont sortis aujourd'hui sont des
sous-officiers dont les cas dans la
sécurité intérieure a qui ont vocation à
être très rapidement autonome alors les
élèves choisissent en fonction de leur
classement les postes qui leur sont
proposés donc là vous avez une partie
qui rejoint la gendarmerie mobile donc
dans tous pareils dans toute la france
métropolitaine
environ presque plus d'un tiers et puis
le reste c'est la partie entre le
journal départemental et un plus petit
nombre ont rejoint la garde républicaine
à paris
[Musique]